[Musique]
Je viens de la Terre une planète sur les lois mon
nom est Peter quill il y a un autre
nom que vous pourriez me connaître par star-lord
vous êtes déjà allé à imax pour voir quoi que ce soit
sur l'espace vous pouvez approfondir c'est l'
espace et l'imagination fusionnant  d'une
manière brillante et colorée,
je suis le grand gars expérimenté,
surtout si c'est un film épique,
le film a l'air incroyable, le monde
qu'ils ont construit est énorme quand je vais voir un
film Imax qui est vraiment fait pour être dans
ce format c'est quand  rend vraiment
l'expérience théâtrale parfaite, nous l'avons
conçue, vous savez spécifiquement pour l'
expérience Imax que vous ajoutez comme un
perfectionniste hyper-intelligent peaufinant
chaque image de ce film, il y a
cette séquence de poursuite de pod qui est tellement
incroyable que je regarde cette chose dans mon
esprit  soufflé est devenu génial c'est ça
les SAT qui étaient Bell qui étaient réels
ils n'ont pas l'air d'être juste
séparés de ce que font les acteurs
je suppose que nous sommes coincés partenaires oh
ouais c'est visuellement différent d'un  ything que vous
avez déjà vu dans votre vie,
vous voulez le voir dans imax
pour que vous l'appréciiez dans son intégralité, je
me suis senti très chanceux d'avoir l'
opportunité de créer quelque chose qui était
destiné au public et à apprécier
ensemble, c'est beaucoup  de rires et certains
drames pourraient même faire couler quelques larmes c'est un
festin visuel que vous devez en quelque sorte voir
en imax
vous